[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host ken
coleman ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
ken's show the ken coleman show deals
with careers you getting the job you
love his brand new book that came out
last week uh went on sale last week
we've been pre-selling it but it hit the
actual shelves and shipped into your
mailbox
and so forth last week from paycheck to
purpose the
clear path to doing work you love
on the heels of that book actually
launching on the street date last week
we are launching pre-sale yesterday on
uh the first book i've done in eight
years
it's called baby steps millionaires how
ordinary people built extraordinary
wealth and how you can too it's on
pre-sale now you can get it at
ramseysolutions.com you can get ken's
book at ramseysolutions.com
uh the pre-sale on mine like all of our
others has a whole bunch of goodies in
it including audio books and e-books and
100 worth of stuff to go with it so
check out books they are available a lot
of things you can't get this year for
christmas these books you'll be able to
get well baby steps comes out in january
but um
but you can go ahead and do the pre-sale
and put the uh i don't know wrap up
something under the tree yeah you put a
picture of it or something in a stocking
maybe take a picture by the way speaking
of pictures put it in ken's book i like
seeing the oh yeah thank you very much
thank you dave i appreciate that the
gift that keeps on giving uh so i like
the new picture by the way i mean not
only is it the first book in eight years
but we've got a uh updated pick looking
pretty cool there standing in the meadow
i mean i like the whole scene there it
looks like the sun rising did you take
that at six in the morning yeah we did
we went out to my farm and did a photo
shoot as as the sun was coming up yeah
it's fun and uh they did a really good
job with it um
and you know photoshop is amazing i've
said that yeah
i've said that i i one of my main
objectives with putting my face a little
bit because of people if i ever get the
privilege to meet people they're gonna
go wow
yeah whoa they really really glamor shot
at you
know our team does a great job so it's
it's good it's exciting stuff fun times
yeah fun times so check it all out at
ramseysolutions.com meantime here the
phone number is triple eight eight two
five five
two two five manissa is with us in
austin texas hi menissa how are you
hi dave i'm doing good how you doing
better than i deserve what's up so i was
calling because
you don't know this but you your books
helped me to get out of credit card debt
good for you
thank you i started with my by myself
trying to to take care of myself and
then i showed my my parents but they
were skeptics and my mom finally got on
board and then my dad got on board so we
no longer have credit card debt
um however now we're in the dilemma
where the house that we purchased
was a wreck so we had to sell it to an
investor and we're in limbo we don't
have
anywhere to
go
the housing market is so bad we keep
getting outbid for houses
and we tried buying a trailer house and
there's issue with land so
i'm i'm thinking i needed to go there
regularly to find out how do i invest so
that i can
build my wealth i i know i i your
one of the sections in your books is to
get an emergency fund
and then do 401 of course i had already
had my 401
and
but i for some reason i can't get the
thousand dollars
i can't even get a hundred dollars and i
don't know what that is so i was hoping
maybe you can leave me in the right
direction okay uh who's we
your parents and you are doing all this
together
i try to do it on my own i thought it
was a book i mean i mean you're like
you're like the house you own you own
with your parents
yes we did it but we we had to sell it
because it was so it's sold so you don't
currently own a house with your parents
no sir we were trying to buy good don't
don't don't own a house with your
parents how old are you
i'm 52. don't own a house with your
parents
well they need me
well they they they can get a place to
rent you can help take care of them but
you don't need to own a house with your
parents this is this is a bad plan
yeah i completely agree with you okay
good then don't do it
yeah so how much of the money did you
get money from the sale of the other
property
um because we had to sell it to a home
investor we didn't really get that much
but we have 15 000
you have how much um
15 000 okay and so you have 7 500 for
them and 7 500 for you right
i will they can have all of it i i mean
you're going to give them all of it okay
then what do you make a year
um
about 41 000 okay and how did you get
out of debt
we just
did your baby steps
well that's baby step one's a thousand
dollars you said you couldn't do that
well then like we
that so i've been trying to to do that
but every time something comes up that
we need to start getting the money out
okay there's not a win you're 52.
there's a them and a you
yes there's no we
yes sir okay so you make 41 000 a year
and how did you pay off credit card debt
well um
so at first you got on a budget and you
found money in the budget and you put it
on the credit cards right
well uh what i did was that we took all
of the bills and the one that was the
lowest we just split them
the balance three ways and we we paid
that and then we paid
we did that for each one of the bills
until we got them all paid off
okay all right so you found the money in
your personal income to apply to the
debt correct yes yes sir so that's how
you do your thousand dollars
only now it's gonna be you and you need
to go find an inexpensive place to rent
give them the 15 000 set up your life
and begin to work the baby steps with a
written budget you're not doing a budget
and you need to start doing a budget
immediately
so get on every dollar and download the
the world's best budgeting app and get
your get your budget going to where you
are doing this but monisa you have to
separate
you can love mom and dad
but you're 52 years old time to move out
of your mother's basement
time to quit sharing bills with your mom
and dad it is way past time
unless you have some kind of a mental
disorder that doesn't enable you to live
on your own
but you need to do that and you need to
do it now and i don't think you do based
on talking to you yeah i i would just
add one thing when he said i want you to
ask yourself
you said they need me
but i wonder how much you need them and
you're not even aware of how much
they're a safety net for you for you not
to truly fly and to do what you're
supposed to be doing i think you've got
to really confront that i think at 52
it's time as dave said for you to strike
out and do your own thing and at 41 000
a year you can get that a thousand
dollar emergency fund pretty quickly
yeah and move through this and before
you know it
be truly in a great place financially
get the least expensive thing don't buy
a trailer
they go down in value get the least
expensive thing you can get to rent get
yourself started
get and take all the extra jobs you can
take and get on a written budget and
begin to build the thousand dollars and
then work your way on up through all of
the baby steps and you'll be just fine
you can do this
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at ziprecruiter
have made the whole job search way
easier ziprecruiter is rated the number
one job site in the us by g2 and it's
free so how does it work first go to
ziprecruiter.com
ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
zip recruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile they can
personally invite you to apply for the
job so if you're ready for an easier job
search check out ziprecruiter sign up
for free right now at ziprecruiter.com
ken that's ziprecruiter.com slash ken
sign up today absolutely free and let
zip recruiter work for you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the ramsey show ken coleman
ramsey personality number one
best-selling author with his new book
from paycheck to purpose the clear path
to doing work you love is answering your
career and job questions i'm answering
your money questions we're answering
your live questions together you jump in
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five two two
ahmed as ahmed is with us ahmed in green
bay wisconsin hi how are you
hi dave i'm doing good how are you
better than i deserve what's up
so currently
i'm trying to transition from just
working as a gig worker i'm trying to
get into the cyber security field and i
was wondering if i should
get a degree or just work on it on my
own and get certification that way
certification uh there is no evidence
anywhere and i would welcome your
research to prove me wrong but there's
no research that would bear out that a
degree is going to help you get into
cyber security faster and make more
money in fact there's such a demand in
this industry and it is white hot it is
probably the most uh not just fastest
growing but the most opportunity long
term with cyber security and uh i i
endorse a program called bethel tech and
they can train you in nine months for if
you cash flow less than thirteen
thousand dollars that's just one example
do your homework look at other people as
well
but you don't need a degree to get into
cyber security if you get certified and
while you're getting certified you are
making connections in the field talking
to folks that are working in cyber
security getting ideas from them
companies that are hiring directions to
go within cyber security
those two things getting certified and
getting connected is all you need to do
to get in
a four-year information systems degree
is an excellent degree field the
technical items you learn while doing
that are obsolete by the time you finish
the degree yeah
they're of no value
i've got we got a thousand team members
here i've got an in-depth security teams
internet
cyber security team obviously we've got
a lot of web presence and
uh a lot at risk and so we spend a lot
of time and money on cyber security and
a four-year degree in information
systems is not a requirement to join a
team our size we do look for the
certifications in this and we do want to
see uh that you've got some kind of
hands-on experience
actually fighting to keep the hackers
out which is the full-time freaking job
these days but um yeah ken's exactly
right this is not a four-year degree
world the technology field in general is
not a four-year degree world
if you want to get it that's fine
but what you're after there is if what
you're after is the ability to get hired
it's not necessary
as a matter of fact it's not even
preferable because what you're learning
is processes and concepts not the
technical hands-on application
because the stuff you learned today
a year and a half from now be obsolete
you've got to have your hands on this
stuff to know what's going on in that
world
you blink and it all changes again
uh you know how your computer is uh
obsolete ken
you got it out of the box isn't that the
truth that's how about how it works this
freaking thing's a door stop six months
later that's right the number of times i
replace technology around here is
unbelievable the money we spend just to
stay
not on cutting edge but just to stay up
to speed cyber security included but
even hardware issues as well bobby's
with us in columbia south carolina hey
bobby welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave uh and it's george right uh
this is ken today but i'll answer this
with me george was with me yesterday
oh very nice and dave i just want to say
thank you both um george is nicer than
ken yeah yeah
i can't i can't argue that he's the
nicest person on the planet he is yeah
he's nicer than all of us that's good
stuff good personality qualities right
there right yeah okay sorry about all
that how can we help
i'm basically you know recommended to
you from a previous boss and a long time
friend of mine uh you know very humble
man man of god brandon blake thank you
very much i hope you hear this um i'm
kind of in a pickle right now dave i'm
24 years old i'm a young father i got a
three-year-old he'll be three in
december absolute pride and joy in my
life and my biggest form of motivation
um and my wife and me we're still
together
um i'm currently living with some
relatives
and i've been here for about seven
months uh my wife was working full-time
and just switched to staying at home to
watching her son while i work full time
i just got a really nice job the best
one i've had since i've been working in
the professional field 401k offered paid
time off
bonus structure things of that nature
i'm in a very weird position though with
how to take you know i'm very young with
my professional career i want to set up
my foundation with investing properly
as we stand right now my debt i only
have about twenty thousand dollars of
debt seventeen thousand dollars in
student loans about two thousand dollars
in medical bills and how much do you
make
um thirty five thousand dollars a year
um if my bonus comes out the way that it
should this next year it'll be at 40.
working 40 hours
40 hours a week yes sir
your baby's how old uh he'll be three in
december december 6.
what was your wife doing before she quit
she was working as a cake decorator for
lowe's foods
and has since lost her position
mainly due to it was during covid so it
got pretty hectic
and right now she's just staying at home
and interestingly enough she also has an
international business degree four-year
university from rollins
but she doesn't have any direct
experience working in the field um not
even a job like a starting job that
would even be relatable to that yeah
what's the pickle that you're in you've
given us a lot of details what's the
pickle
my pickle is i have two options right
now um you know eventually inevitably i
want to move out uh my mom and dad are
generous enough to allow me a little
allow me to live rent free um something
i'm having is living expenses and a
couple other payments
um but i need to figure out you know if
i mean obviously saving money is what
needs to happen um but where to put that
money is the question no there's not a
question you're you're broke and you're
living with your parents you need to
pile up some money in the savings
account and get out of there
yeah you don't need to start don't worry
about investing and don't start your
401k you're broken in debt
and you guys have got to do something in
this household to increase your incomes
so since you're only working 40 hours
you need an extra job and your wife
needs to start doing some freaking cake
decorating while she's at home with a
three-year-old
yeah no you're right you're not wrong
dave um and i guess my next question is
you know to make my the smartest
decision possible um you know my credit
score is pretty good at 700.
um my thought process was
getting either a mortgage on a house no
you're broke
you need to go get a one bedroom or two
bedroom apartment as cheap as you can
get and you need to pile up cash as much
as you can and you need to be working 80
hours a week and she needs to start
working 30 hours a week when the kids
down
so she can get some other income coming
in you guys need to get your income up
50 to 70 000 immediately and start
paying these debts off and get out from
under your parents roof yesterday
yes sir my question is in regards to the
rent with renting i mean as you know
rental properties the money you put in
goes into a hole you don't get it back
honey you're broke
you're a renter
you don't buy a house when you're broke
you are broke and in debt you make
thirty five thousand dollars a year have
a three-year-old you're 24 years old you
don't go buy a house right now this
house will be a curse to you you're
trying to mix long-term
issues in with your short-term
emotions and you need to get the
short-term stuff taken care of you need
a big pile of money for an emergency and
to move and to get out and you guys need
to get your incomes up and then you
begin to attack the debt and when the
debt is gone you build an emergency fund
a fully funded big emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses then
we'll start talking about saving for a
house you're not buying a house for
three two to three years from today if
you're wise
it's just hard dave because you know
with rent it's not hard
an additional it's not hard you're 24
you'll be 27 when you own your first
house it's not hard at all yeah somebody
has told you that renting is throwing
money away and you can't get past that
thought and it's simply not throwing
money away for two years when stacy and
i moved here to join dave this was the
move for me
we took two years and rented because we
wanted to make sure we were going to the
right place we wanted to make sure that
we were going to lock in and and dive in
and we had to save money to be able to
get the kind of house that we felt that
we wanted to get we weren't throwing
money away that's a false narrative and
you're not hearing the wisdom and the
truth here that dave just gave you the
baby steps work every time but only if
you get this mindset out of your head
that renting is wasting money renting is
buying patience while you're too broke
to buy oh that's good
you're buying you're buying time
and honey you're so broke you live with
your parents
that's how broke you are you don't need
to go from that to owning a home
you you need to get out get the debts
paid off build up an emergency fund
build a foundation for your young family
slow your butt down
you're okay you got plenty of time
this is the ramsay shop
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much pure
talk gives you the same great 5g
coverage on the same 5g network as one
of the big guys for half the cost the
average family saves over 800 a year go
to puretalk.com and choose the
affordable plan that's right for you
with their 30-day risk-free guarantee
you have nothing to lose go to
puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today in the lobby of ramsey solutions
on the debt-free stage richie and carol
are with us hey guys how are you
doing good how about you better than i
deserve welcome where do you guys live
oxfield tennessee
knoxville all right good people i was
born just south of there in maryville
marvel mara
you have to say that correctly yes all
right so how much debt have you guys
paid off we paid off seventy nine
thousand five hundred and fifteen
dollars and fifty cents all right how
long did this take it took us 23 months
good for you and your range of income in
that two years um we started off at 58
000 and then we're on track this year to
be at about 108 000. wow
there we go
what do you guys do for a living
i'm an elementary school music teacher
and i'm in sales okay so worth the extra
50 grand in income i mean you doubled
your freaking income we did um so i
started off in a smaller job with not so
much pay and then um right after the
cove pandemic when school started
opening up i um was hired into my
teaching position oh so you got like a
full big job pretty much
you're working like part time kind of
yeah pretty much yes and sales is good
obviously it's god's ups and downs yeah
okay all right so eighty thousand
dollars in debt what was it what kind of
debt
it was a little bit of everything we um
it was credit cards car truck uh
motorcycles cruise loans crews we paid
off a cruise
so
yes we did unfortunately look at you
awesome
okay so what happened two years ago how
y'all been married uh six and a half
years okay so uh after four years of
marriage or three years of marriage
someone says this ramsey stuff we gotta
try tell me how this happened what
happened so um it happened a little bit
before um i had found out about you
through some friends and so i started
listening to your podcast and looking
through all your tools and everything
and i told him i said hey let's try this
he's like no i'm not interested no i
don't want to do this
and then about two years ago
he had an emergency appendectomy oh and
so i was sitting in the emergency room
waiting and i was like there's no way
because with my income if something
worse were to happen
we couldn't be able to pay our bills we
and i was i was in freak out boat
and so
when we got home from the appendectomy i
looked at him and i said we have to do
now that you lived if you don't do this
i'm gonna kill you yeah
pretty much
and so um that was kind of our i had it
moment um
and so since then we
really really buckled down um and it
took him a little bit to get on board
but i mean first couple times i'd
you know she was just like let's try
this dave ramsey thing and
um i was just like no i just i was
stubborn just like everybody else is
well i'm a salesman i always tried to
outsell my stupidity and right i tried
to i just tried to out earn it right
yeah and so after uh after the the
surgery i was just like okay let's give
it a shot and
we started off we had a little bit of
money put back and we paid off one of
our credit cards
and as soon as i paid off that credit
card i've got a massive adrenaline rush
and i was just like okay what else can
we pay off
that's when he finally was on board um
and then we finally were able to
start really getting some debt paid off
so i was catching the youtube uh feed
through my peripheral vision while i was
looking at y'all i saw the motorcycle
pop up did you keep it or did you sell
it no i actually sold it to pay off uh
the hospital the appendectomy oh she
told me she said not a good trade no no
that's an appendix for a motorcycle
that's just not okay
well we um that was part of our debt we
paid off the motorcycle and then we
turned around and sold it to pay off the
medical debt what did it sell for it
looks like a great bike it uh i sold it
for 2500 oh wow and that that covered
everything and i told her when i sold it
naturally i said so we pay this off and
after we're debt-free yeah i want to buy
another bike and she said okay
absolutely
yeah that's that's what you live like no
one else later you can live like no one
else exactly ride like no one else later
you can ride like no one else yes that's
good way to go man cool very cool thank
you so you guys just when you once that
adrenaline hit you leaned in and 23
months later boom boom we did there was
some struggles of course where what was
the biggest struggle
uh
probably um having to say no a lot and
being like no we can't go out no we
can't do this or do that no we don't
need that even though your friends look
at you like you lost your mind they did
they were like
what just go out and have fun everyone's
going to be in debt everyone's going to
have debt just go out and have fun and
we're like no we don't want to do that
we don't want to be in debt anymore it's
wearing us down it's worn us down our
entire marriage and we just don't want
to do it anymore so i i love when when
couples share the struggle
i want to know in your situation
what did you two do for each other or
individually to keep pressing on through
the struggle
what kept you moving we um we had to be
each other's rock yes there were times
where he wanted to quit where i was like
no
we're doing so well we have to do this
we have to keep going there were times i
wanted to quit and he said no no we
can't you know we just we really had to
push each other to keep going um i mean
and and we would pull up the podcast we
would listen um dave we watched your
story a lot on youtube about where you
came from and where you're at now and
brought me in tears every single year to
hear the story
it was just one of those things where we
had to remind ourselves what we're doing
it for um so later on when we have kids
of our own that they don't have to live
like we did yeah i love that i want to
ask you take me to one of those moments
well either one of me i don't care but
what did you say i know that you were
each other's rock but what was that
thing maybe that you said besides
watching dave's story and seeing that
desire future certainly that's
motivating but what'd you say to each
other hey
stick with us what'd you say we would be
out somewhere it didn't matter what
story went to if we wanted to buy
something that we knew we could take
that 20 40 50 whatever towards debt
and
naturally my immediate response is
because i want her to you know she wants
to buy something i want her to have it
sure naturally and at the end of the day
i would be like you know if you want it
by and then we'd sit there and stare at
each other and be like what would dave
say
we would be like
we would get down in kind of a well i'm
tired i don't want to do this anymore
and we would be like what would dave say
like what would dave do at this point
and i think that kind of kept us going a
lot and also i mean it's like this past
weekend i had a funeral i had to go to
my uncle passed away in hernando florida
so we drove there and back
and the 10-hour drive back i can promise
you we had 10 hours of dave ramsey in
the car oh my god we did i don't even
want to be in the car
and it also took a lot of prayer too a
lot of prayer
trust you know god telling us
so you did it all off the podcast or the
total money makeover book or financial
piece university we did financial peace
university
we did it um in our home we didn't do
the class um i think during the pandemic
well yeah online yeah um and so we
didn't during the pandemic most mostly
is when we watched it sure um but that
really helped us to kind of figure out
our direction and where we need to go so
proud of y'all thank you y'all are
amazing what a great couple thank you
you just really you got the right spirit
on you you're going to be able to do
anything you want to do you're on your
way to being baby steps millionaires
before you know it now that you hit this
stride so very very well done we got a
copy of uh the legacy journey for you to
celebrate that next chapter and a copy
total money makeover for you to give
away to somebody help get them started
because you've been talking about this
you can't shut up about it i actually
gave um i gave the total money makeover
book to a co-worker mine she was
struggling
and when i gave it to her
she did like what anybody else would do
even i've done it put the book aside
yeah i asked her i said have you read
the book
and she said
no i haven't read it yet i said okay
now i'd come back next day hey have you
picked up the book yet she says no
and so finally i met her at work one day
and she said hey i wanted to tell you
something i said what's that she said
that book that you and carol gave me i
said yes she said me and my husband were
having a um
a struggle a fuss over money we don't
have any money right now and i said okay
and she said i prayed to god and asked
him
to help me and she said god told me i
gave you a book
[Laughter]
all right guys count it down 80 000 paid
off in 23 months making 58 to 108.
let's hear a dead free scream three
[Applause]
wow
that'll preach this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well last week was launch day on ken
coleman's new book from paycheck to
purpose they were shipped to your
mailbox if you ordered one if you
haven't gotten one yet you can get it
now we'll ship it to you immediately the
clear path to doing work you love and
then yesterday we released pre-sale on
the first book i have done in eight
years it is called baby steps
millionaires how ordinary people built
extraordinary wealth and how you can too
it's all about step-by-step how to
exactly become a millionaire and i prove
to you
without without beyond a shadow of a
doubt
that you c that you
you know i'm talking to you
that you
can do this
that's pretty cool
it's not out of reach it's doable
so if you want to pre-order this book
actually comes out january the 11th but
it went on sale on pre-sale yesterday
when you pre-purchase a ramsey book we
typically bribe you to buy it early by
giving you a whole bunch of goodies and
this is no exception baby steps
millionaire audio book and e-book is
included in the 20
the legacy journey audio book and ebook
is included in the twenty dollars the
baby steps millionaire's live stream
event in january is included in the
twenty dollars a ramsey smart tax tax
filing is included for free in the
twenty dollars and a 30 day free trial
for ramsey plus is included
in the twenty dollars it's over a
hundred almost two hundred dollars worth
of stuff included when you buy a twenty
dollar book now
that's pretty cool so be sure and check
all of that out danielle is with us in
philadelphia hi danielle welcome to the
ramsay show
hi there hi what's up
so a little over a year ago
i married my long time boyfriend and
we're not young we're
late 40s early 50s and
we still have two houses now a year
later because
his house is an hour and a half away
from my job
i spend about two hundred and forty
dollars a month in gasoline going back
and forth i don't do it every day how
far is your house from his job
um
maybe two hours
so you guys work you guys work two hours
apart
yes
that's wild
his his job is actually an hour and a
half from his house as well but he's
willing to make that sacrifice i
i'm not i think i think it's cray cray
i think you need to sell both these
houses and buy a house close to your
jobs
well
i agree with that
however i have been in the mindset
lately of well perhaps maybe i could
look for a job closer but my dilemma is
that i have been working in the school
district for 25 years
as a custodial supervisor
and i make about sixty eight thousand
dollars a year
my concern is going someplace else and
not making that kind of money i work my
way up to where i am now
there's also another reason i keep my
house because i have extended family
also living in this house right now
why
[Applause]
my daughter had two young children and
she got a divorce
and was only making about 13 an hour so
she had a hard time maintaining anything
and um so you're paying a house payment
for her
correct so when's she gonna get on her
feet
well she just got a promotion uh she
started last week
and um it should bump her up to about
twenty dollars
come next month
you need a plan for her to be on her own
and you just sell that house and you
guys ought to sell the house that you
live in
and you ought to move closer to both of
your jobs
this is tough
his job he's making over
a hundred thousand so and he's just a
bus driver in new york city
so um okay so hold on i got to jump in
i'm going crazy so both of you make good
money and you both are assuming that you
can't do anything else so i want to i
want to frame what you've been doing a
little differently
you're not just a supervisor of
custodians in a education system you are
a leader of people in a specific area
you're a leader oh
it's true oh it's absolutely true well
listen i'm the queen around here i know
you are and here's the deal you got a
lot of experience i just heard some sass
come out we are in the hottest job
market in the history of the united
states and you have something to offer
years and years of experience of leading
people that are in uh you know the
traditional custodial roles and things
of that nature there's a lot of options
for you out there i would also say we
have the greatest need in the history of
the united states in the area of drivers
whether it be
your traditional 18 wheelers or other we
have a supply chain problem and i saw an
article just last week there's a need
right now in the united states danielle
for 80 000 truck drivers if he's driving
a bus in manhattan he can drive
something else you guys have got to get
outside of this mindset that we can't
make what we make or more somewhere else
because i don't believe that's true and
you at least owe it to yourselves to do
the research yeah investigate see what
else is out there
i mean you're like there's only one kind
of spaghetti but you've never been to
more than one restaurant that's right i
mean go check out some spaghetti
restaurants keto go look at the jobs
that are on the plate out there and see
what's happening you have a lot of
experience and skill to offer and not to
mention you're the queen that's right
well that comes that the royalty part
should go a long way
i like that yeah and here's the other
thing a house is a stupid house
yeah i ain't driving an hour and a half
for a stupid house oh that's too [ __ ]
you another stupid house
there's stupid houses on every corner
and this idea that you know i'm not well
i've always lived so what
sell it
i am not driving an hour and a half over
a job or a piece of real estate all of
these things can change and we didn't
even discuss the potential financial
gain from those two houses yeah assuming
what their what their position is in
them
absolutely we got to get daughter up and
out so she can sell that other house but
still oh my gosh y'all there's a lot of
stuff going on here
and you guys are holding on to the past
so tightly you're not going to live well
in the future
yeah the past job history the past i
worked so hard to get here so use that
to go into something else
i've always lived here so use that to
get into something else don't hold on to
the past so tight that you lose your
future all right jeff is with us in
tulsa oklahoma hi jeff how are you
hi dave thanks so much for taking my
call i really appreciate your time we're
honored how can we help
well i'm 56 years old and uh we're in
baby step seven and i heard you say
something recently that got me to
thinking and that is that social
security basically is a break even if
that and i was wondering what the
advantages or disadvantages
would be like if i were to take out my
social security uh as early as i can
62.65 whatever the age is and invest
that money and if they take it in 62 and
invest it and don't touch it you'll end
up with more money
yes sir
that's what'll happen that's my question
yeah so the difference in what you get
paid
if you wait to 65
versus 62 would be made up for in the
investment that you create
by investing everything from 62 to 65.
if you take all that put in a lump sum
that lump sum will pay more than it
would pay extra if you wait oh and when
you die that money is in your estate
when you die with social security it
disappears
magical government math
just gone poof just like that oh yeah
yeah
yeah the social insecurity system gives
you a negative rate of return
it is an absolute
governmental disaster
think dmv runs retirement program now
you got it figured out okay this is
what's going on and so well it was never
designed to be retired programs designed
to be a supplemental yeah it's designed
to be supplemental and a whole bunch of
people are living on it because we've
raised a couple generations now that
think the government is so smart they're
going to take care of you
and if you wait on the government to
take care of you your life is always
going to suck
so he's right just really smart to ask
that question
and say i'm not going to count on social
insecurity when i get to retirement
because i'm going to have actually saved
some of my own money oh and when i do
get the money from the government i'll
never get as much out as i have put in
that means you have a negative rate of
return you don't even get out as much as
you put in
unless you just live to 192
you know and so you're it's a negative
rate of return they are sucking the
blood
out of the american public continually
with this disaster of a program
nobody gonna do anything about it though
just but i'll whine a little it's good
for me yeah helps my blood pressure yeah
ken coleman good show this hour and uh
james child's going to show this hour
jenna on the phones good job this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king
and the paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host ken coleman
ramsey personality number one
best-selling author and author of the
brand new book from paycheck to purpose
the clear path to doing work you love is
my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five five two two five kelsey is
with us in connecticut hi kelsey how are
you
hi dave hi ken this is exciting i wasn't
expecting this today well we're honored
to have you how can we help
um i have a career question so my boss
has just asked me if i wanted to take
over her small business it's a gym i'm a
personal trainer but i was actually
planning to join the air force in the
next year and now i'm i just feel lost
like i don't know what opportunity to do
oh
well this is a fun place to be in uh but
i think we've got to simplify this so
your head and heart were totally focused
on going into the air force for a future
there and when your boss hit you with
this it felt really good did it felt
nice that she would trust you enough and
it felt very nice correct
yeah yeah
yeah good but after that wore off
and you begin to really wrestle with
well wait a second i think i was heading
over here what was your heart telling
you right before you made this phone
call which way were you leaning because
i know you were leaning one way
yeah so i've really been leaning towards
the air force i've i've actually been
thinking about that since last um last
march i've just been like
head and heart in there i just couldn't
do it sooner because of medical reasons
good but um so here's the deal i just so
here's the deal are you worried about
letting your boss down or are you
worried maybe what others might say
about turning this on paper
really amazing opportunity to run a
business what's really making you
question what you know you want to do
that's what you have to answer right now
what is what is causing the doubt about
the military decision
um it's a woman's gym and
i'm afraid that if i don't take it over
it's gonna close and
i just care about the members a lot got
it okay that's amazing now kelsey you
got to be careful here
to
not misinterpret what is a really
beautiful heart you're a good person and
you have built relationships with those
women you care about them you've
invested in them and if you're not
careful that false guilt
is going to turn into resentment if you
were to do this and take this all for
the right heart reasons
you will be delaying and maybe
completely moving on from the thing that
you know you're supposed to do and i'm
telling you that will eventually turn
into resentment and you have no reason
to feel guilt
about not taking this business those
women will find other places to work out
you didn't open it you didn't open it
and it's not your responsibility to take
care of their physical life do you
understand what i'm saying
yeah it makes it makes a lot of sense i
think like i talked to my family about
it and of course my family's just gonna
tell me to do
what you know what i should do but i
i just needed like an honest
not family oriented opinion to kind of
steer me in the right direction let's
refocus for just a moment tell me in 30
seconds or less from your heart
what the future is because you're moving
into the air force what's that look like
and why are you doing it
um
[Music]
the opportunity to travel
meet a lot of
new people go different places and
just serve our country which is
something i've been thinking about for a
while that's that's all you need to
focus on there's no guilt here you do
what you believe you're supposed to do
there's no guilt those ladies are gonna
be fine
one of them can take it and run it yeah
you're free kelsey i would do it yeah
thank you
yeah
thanks for the call thank you for being
willing to serve our country you're a
great american absolutely
absolutely incredible
well done all right open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five tyler's in fayetteville arkansas hi
tyler how are you
good how are you dave better than i
deserve what's up so um my main question
is so i'm in the military right now and
what i'm kind of struggling with is
whether or not i should
purchase a home while i'm on active duty
or wait until i transition to the
reserves
um right now that looks like a six year
timeline
um just to give you some stats i have no
debt i have about three hundred thousand
dollars invested um
with a tsp two roth iras
and a taxable brokerage account good for
you um
yeah oh thank you how much is in the
broker
i have about
190 000 in there i believe way to go all
right and how how often will they move
you and during the next six years while
you're still active duty
so i'm in yeah i'm in fort bragg right
now in fayetteville and i will move in
about three years and i eventually uh
after my sixth year want to transition
to the reserves and go to where my
parents yep yeah so you don't need to
buy
and it's not because you are the money
you have the money but the problem is
you're going to be moving
and you're in an area that the uh
the properties are largely military
properties
and so you've got a lot of properties
coming on the market because they're
always moving people
and uh it's a little tougher to move a
property in one of these military towns
agreed oh i agree oh i absolutely agree
that's what i was thinking too because
my parents actually just recently moved
to nashville
and
knowing how the housing market is there
me and my wife are trying to decide
whether or not to just keep investing
and piling cash and then have a
ginormous down payment yes
and then buy buy once you've settled
into a place
once you settle into wherever it is
you're settling into
and it's probably after your military
career when you move into the reserves
after your active duty career and thanks
for your service because you're moving
so often that you the house is not going
to go up enough in value and it's hard
to sell them sometimes and you can get
stuck with properties everywhere you've
been stationed
and so when you're moving every two to
three years almost always it's better
off to rent and just pile up some cash
over here for when you settle in now
some branches of the military some jobs
in the military after a while in the
career you will settle in and be in one
location even while active duty for a
long time if you're going to be there a
while like five years plus then yeah you
start talking about buying
but most of you guys and gals are moved
every two to three years and most of
these markets do not support enough
turnover and do not support a price
increase to justify buying when you're
only holding two to three years you'll
lose money on the transaction if you can
sell it or you'll get stuck with the
thing and end up with rental properties
dotted all over the nation
and you don't want to do that so but
again thank you for your service as well
yeah his theme
is one of my favorite scenes from
braveheart
where the the english are thundering
down the cavalry on wallace and his men
and he says hold
hold
hold
and that's going to be a great position
when you get out exactly right
exactly right i love it this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
well we're coming into that time of year
when some people get all stressed out
about money it's called christmas
the gifts the travel expenses the extra
food the bills
oh and life still has to go on
but what if money was something that you
never had to fret about stress about
worry about
again what if christmas was actually
like enjoyable and stuff
well you'd need a plan to cause that to
happen and we can show you how to do it
it's called financial peace university
this is the place where we teach you how
to handle money how to get out of debt
how to build wealth how to be
outrageously generous how to live on a
budget how to live on a plan it's the
class you should have been made to take
back when you're in high school but
back then nobody made you take it
financial peace university and our
premium version of every dollar the
world's best budgeting app
goes with financial peace university
when you become a ramsey plus member it
gives you access to all of this stuff
and much more if you want a free trial
of ramsay plus to try all this out go to
ramseysolutions.com
ramseyplus our question of the day comes
from blinds.com they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee that means even
if you mismeasure or you pick the wrong
color they'll remake your window blinds
for free you get free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run every month you'll save even more
it's an incredible american company
blinds.com
use ramsay to get the best deal today's
question comes from daniel in maine i
got a job at a major law firm after my
first year of law school i am now a
third year law student and the firm i
work for wants to hire me after
graduation i would like to own my own
law firm someday and feel like gaining
experience in a smaller firm would be
better to prepare me to achieve that
goal would i be crazy to reject a higher
paying job at a respected law firm to
pursue my dreams you wouldn't be crazy
but i want to challenge this thought
that
you saying
no to this bigger firm
and going to work for a smaller firm is
going to somehow prepare you to run your
own firm better because you picture it
being a smaller firm i actually think
that i would consider
what you could learn
from working for a bigger firm and
understanding the complexities of the
business and i think that's just as
relevant as you would scale down uh
eventually running your own firm so i i
don't know that this is the actual right
narrative that well
if i work for a smaller firm that's
going to better prepare me to run my own
small firm one day i think leadership is
leadership
organization is organization and i think
you'd learn in some ways more from a
larger firm and getting to know their
leaders and those partners and learning
from them taking the higher pay and then
if you feel like that you can get
something unique from a smaller firm
let's move to that eventually so i
wouldn't assume this is the right choice
either way
you've got to learn how to run a
business that's correct
and so the more time you spend being a
lawyer
and the less time you spend on actually
building business acumen regardless of
which location you're in
that's going to take away from your
dream so your dream is you need to
become a great lawyer
but also learn how to run a law firm the
business practices of that so uh i i
think you could get the the business
acumen like ken is saying either place
you've just got to be very intentional
about it you're going to run into
the dichotomy that anyone that has a a
specific discipline or skill runs into
uh if you paint houses and you do a
really good job and you want to be a
painter
and you want to own your own painting
contracting firm running a painting
contracting firm is different than
painting
that's a running a business that's a
different set of skills and so the more
you paint houses
the less you will learn about running a
business and the more
chances of you failing running that
business becomes so anybody that's a
maker anyone that's a doer like a lawyer
even a doctor yep the more time you
spend actually being a doctor and not
actually running the practice there are
two different things yeah and you can't
make enough to out earn your stupidity
so you've got to learn these business
skills that's correct regardless of
which place you are and the law the
smaller firm could
eat you up as a lawyer and take up all
your time lawyering
as much as the larger firm does so you
just got to be intentional about
wherever you are learning the business
skills yeah and so i think i'm with ken
i think you take the higher paying job i
do too i i just think that's better
because there's some complexities at the
larger firm that you're going to learn
about
amanda's in nashville hi amanda welcome
to the ramsay show
hi how are you better than i deserve
what's up in your world
um
not a lot i just had a quick question
and i wanted to press this by saying
that i do follow your plan but i've been
trying to diagnose the medical condition
for the past year so i do have a larger
savings than you would approve of
my question is should i refinance my
house to pay off my student loans or
should i sell it pay off the mortgage
pay off the student loans and then rent
until i can buy again it's my husband
and i
um
okay a lot going on here how much is
your student loan debt
uh 137.
what's your degree in
my husband is a chiropractor i'm a
medical assistant
okay and what does he make
he makes around 110 i think is it your
student loan or his
it has
oh
okay
he makes 110.
all right
and um
interesting
and and you make how much
um i make somewhere around 30 but the
household last year i think we brought
home 122 not mistaken
that's going up this year you have 130
000 in student loan debt
yeah 137 137
okay and 63 and savings all together so
you not being able to work is not going
to
because the your income is a the smaller
portion of your household income right
yes and i um
you that have a medical condition or him
it's him oh it's him
oh
so yeah we're both able to work so
you're piling the money up because
waiting on what this diagnosis for him
might be
what has he got
what's going on with him um i'd rather
not say it's just uh something that
we've had to do a couple of diagnostics
on in the past year
okay well depending on how debilitating
it is and how sure
the diagnosis is correct is
uh the more debilitating and the more
sure you are the more i'm just selling
the house
i'm not refinancing and borrowing your
way out of the debt either way
yeah our thought process there was that
we would be able to lower the interest
rate
it's not an interest rate problem it's a
debt problem
okay
and you have a huge pile of debt so if
you sold your home would it pay off the
student loan and the home
oh yeah everything and you'd be free
okay
so if he's not going to be able to earn
that kind of income to be able to pay
off
the student loan
by being a chiropractor that he took out
getting into that he took out to become
a chiropractor because of this medical
diagnosis yeah you need to sell the
house
to reset and to get yourself
positioned to weather this health storm
okay now the the other question is this
um are the other thing to bring up and
because i i
you intentionally are
i've got an incomplete picture because
you're uh
concerned about privacy and i that's
okay all right but let me let me give
you two other pieces of information that
might enter into this when is are these
uh
federal student loans
uh yes they are right now okay well they
need to stay federal student loans
because if he were to pass away they are
forgiven
okay well it's not anything that's
serious it's just more of a yeah it's a
if he were be to be declared permanently
disabled
that's not going to happen either okay
so it's not that extreme okay that's
good yeah nothing extreme good okay so
you're gonna pay them so the only
question is how long is he gonna be with
and you're gonna you just have you guys
have to assess this
the longer he's gonna be out of work or
have
hugely diminished income the more i'm
going to lean towards selling the house
but if it's a one-year thing and you
want to hold on that's fine hold on put
the student loans on hardship deferral
come back from the mess and get the
income back up and attack the student
loans and get rid of them i'd be okay
with that yeah i think the other factor
here is how expensive could the
treatment be i felt like there was a
little hint towards that and that's why
i'd still sell the house sets you free
you got plenty of cash plenty of freedom
and income to be able to pay for the
treatment well when you come back and
you're making you're making a hundred
thousand dollars again
after the other side of this and just
buy another house i agree that'd be an
okay thing to do too
this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
uh
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage marcia and cameron are
with us hey guys how are you great how
you doing yeah welcome where do you guys
live uh fort branch indiana just outside
of evansville all right well we got to
get started with i love
the t-shirts
be the third pig
the back is even better what's this on
the back we're debt-free
that's right brick house be the pig in
the brick house the third pig
i love it way to go you guys you're
prepared for the big bad wolf excellent
all right how much debt have you paid
off uh we paid off uh 120 thousand
dollars very good how long did that take
uh about three years once we really got
working together okay and what was your
range of income during that three years
um 90 up to 1 30. cool what do y'all do
for a living
i manage a home improvement center and
i'm the founder and executive director
and non-profit benefiting kids in foster
care oh good very good great good job
you guys okay what kind of debt was the
120 000
well we were very normal we had uh
student loans credit cards medical debt
and uh most recently our house wow
yes we did super weirdo
i'm looking at weird people
looking at weird third pigs i like it so
uh what's this house worth uh 225 ish
that's so fun
your house is paid for dude it feels
weird yeah it's just strange i love it
the grass feels better under your feet
yeah ken and i have a good friend down
in atlanta just sent us a video this
morning he paid off his house showed us
hitting the hitting submit on the
computer and then you see their feet out
in the grass like you're all youtube
pictures a second ago here yeah the
grass feels different under your feet
when you pay for it way to go guys thank
you thank you so very cool all right
there's a story here how long you been
married
13 years okay so three years ago you got
serious yes and you said you did qualify
you said when we finally got together
and both of us were doing it we got
serious it went zoom zoom tell us what
happened and tell us how you got plugged
into ramsey well
our story goes back probably 10 years
i'm probably the the textbook example of
of how not to do things um i stumbled
upon your radio show just driving one
day and
um
kind of dabbled in it didn't really
you know go full force into the baby
steps or anything but i started
listening to you and and
your principles made a lot of sense so
i started doing some of the the steps
and doing some of the things and
my mistake was i did not bring her in on
it so
although i was making a little bit of
progress uh it it was really creating a
pinch point and a
stress in our marriage because we
weren't operating off of the same page
and i'm over here trying to do one thing
and she's doing another thing and it
just it wasn't working out so
well and a little bit of backstory to
that is when we um we lived in kokomo
indiana it was a 2008 during the the
housing crash or flip or whatever it was
and
um
we he's going to tell you a little bit
more about that but but i guess what i
was trying to say was um
dave ramsey was not a good word it was
what were you saying a cuss word in our
family
and i was i was the free spirit that
wanted to do whatever i wanted to do and
i was
even though we talked about what you
were the plan i was i was not having it
no not at all so what happened that
caused you to get together and decide to
do it together
um
well going back near to the beginning of
our story
near there anyway
we were upside down on a house
by a lot
and
we got we moved my job moved us so
we were in a position where we were way
underwater on our house and
um fortunately my my parents have always
been a big help to us and my dad loaned
me some money about twenty thousand
dollars just to be able to sell our
house and you know write the check to
get out of it
um
and then you know fast forward we were
gonna pay him back it was alone and
uh that very next christmas after
christmas dinner uh my dad sat us down
and
said that his present to us was we
didn't own that money back anymore wow
so
um
that really did it for me that was kind
of my why because you know it really got
me thinking you know if i
ever want to be in a position to be able
to bless my kids and my family like that
then i really need to do something
different than i've been doing so um i
don't know really what was it that three
years ago really put us on it together
so another important fact in
10 years ago we actually owed two
hundred and sixteen thousand dollars so
we came a long way as we as we marched
forth uh to three years ago um but three
years ago he he was just so excited
about your principles and he's he
started he started teaching fbu classes
and uh and and sitting in that class he
invited me to really be hands-on and
part of it and and i had started
listening to him and your principles and
and i got excited myself and i became
the i don't want to sit at this table
and talk about this i don't like that
name in my house i want to buy whatever
i want to like come on guys you can do
this and um and really the the where we
got gazelle intense was um during the
pandemic uh just a little over i guess
it's been like 15 months now but my dad
was um he was dying
and he did not leave a good family tree
as far as finances and and we were
really left with a huge mess
and then i have my own
medical issues that that i was told that
i was a big high-risk complications from
kovid and i just it just really was an
eye-opener that i have two amazing kids
and what if something happened to one of
us in this time
how would i what would that mean for my
family and um
and that was it like i was sold i didn't
care from then on else if we were eating
rice and beans being the rice we were
getting everything paid off and so i
called him at work one day and i said
let's do this we can do this and
we're here we did this and we're
grateful and he's like who are you and
what have you done with my wife
[Laughter]
way to go you guys
yeah i just want to know i mean
obviously we heard the whole backstory i
want to know you get really fired up
right and so now we've got big
motivators yeah what was the hardest
part once you actually got into it
because there's that initial high this
must be done right conviction and at
what point did you start to struggle or
did you struggle and what'd you do to
get out of that
yeah we did uh
i think the biggest thing was it was so
different you know we'd never
it was the first time in our marriage
that you know we had really been on the
same page and focusing on the same
common goal and
there's unbelievable power in that you
know we did it for so long
um you know i i we were talking on the
way down here i felt like i was you know
repairing holes in the boat while she's
on the other end drilling bigger ones
and
um you know so just once we really
grasped the concept and started working
together it was so different than
anything we'd ever done that it took us
a while to kind of adjust to that and
getting
accustomed to using a budget and
following the every dollar budget but
you know really once
we started on that same page together it
was game on it's very cool he i used to
be the kind of person that i'd get a
couple hundred dollars from a bonus or
something i'd be like oh he didn't know
and i'm shoving that in the drawer
because i'm gonna go shopping uh and
he'd see it when it showed up on amazon
right on my front door or wherever that
was from um and it just became you know
what we have extra money let's do
something intentional with it let's be
intense and it was it was really just
getting on the same page and actually i
was sharing this this story with
somebody a couple weeks ago about being
able to be on this stage and share such
a a big win for our family and changing
the family tree and
um and i said you know what i think
another big motivator was knowing this
is not like something that somebody else
can do we can do this every day people
can do it if you if you do it on purpose
and i have to give a plug to my son here
let's get the kids in what are their
names and ages uh jackson and harmony
okay so jackson twelve and seven twelve
and seven
so jackson is is i think he was born a
nerd like his dad
um and we gave him the give save spend
pigs uh many years ago and he was really
diligent about giving and saving giving
and saving and um he is going to be 13
in february and by
his 13th birthday he is going to have a
toyota camry paid for with less miles
than my vehicle and
a three thousand dollar savings account
well done
very impressive all right marcia cameron
jackson and harmony for harmony from
evansville indiana 120 000 paid off in
three years making 90 to 130 be the
third pig house and everything count it
down let's hear a debt-free scream three
two
one
we're dead free
wow what a complete transformation
and the reluctant spouse goes in to help
with financial peace university
there it is catches it catches the
disease catches the disease
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is the ramsey show
he's a number one best-selling author
and his brand new book is out from
paycheck to purpose the clear path
to doing work you love patti is with us
in boise idaho hi patty welcome to the
ramsay show
hi thank you for taking my call sure you
had a call a few minutes ago that peaked
my interest and i'm trying to understand
um my husband is losing his job
on friday because he won't take the
coveted shot and his company is firing
everybody that will not do it they're
not doing exemptions or anything
he is almost 62. he'll be 62 in just a
couple of months
and we're trying i'm 51 or 51 so i'm a
little bit younger than he is how has he
been with that company
uh seven years wow okay
um and it's been a lot of it's been a
lot of going back and forth they kept
coming back and forth and saying you're
going you're not you're going you're not
and finally today they just said no
you're going like everybody
that refuses is just gone
so
what we're trying to figure out is
somebody asked you about early
retirement with social security and one
of the things that he and i wondered is
would it be better for him to take early
retirement because we understand that
investing
that would be better but he's not ready
to quit work and i was under the
impression that if you took
early social security that they didn't
you if you are working correct and okay
so you don't get a lump sum that's why
no it's not a lump sum it's monthly
income
okay
if you start your social security at 62
you get a smaller monthly income than if
you started at 65.
but then if he continues to work don't
they doing that social security exactly
they will yeah okay so probably if i
don't if he's gonna go back to work
don't take social security
okay okay
he would not be happy not not
working he's still got years where he's
going to want to be productive he's not
going to want to just well i would hope
so he's just a spring chicken
we're the same age so there you go yeah
you know and he loves what he does i
mean you know most people go to work and
they come home and leave their work at
work he's an inventor and an engineer
and that's what he loves and so he does
it all the time so he's not really ready
to just give that up and so
we weren't sure is taking early
retirement i i from the call it sounded
like the guy was going to take a one
lump sum was so secure
it's not a lump sum they don't offer
lump sum if they did i would have
already taken it okay okay well that
helps thank you early and often as i can
get money from the government that is
mine that i've given them and i'm not
even going to get it all back i would
take all i could get as fast as i could
get it because um they've been screwing
me for years and so i'd be happy to take
some of it back and that sentence you
just uttered is a total fantasy oh i
know i didn't say it would happen i just
said it'd be nice no i know that's what
i'm saying we'll all be doing that yeah
oh boy
we'll turn into this grumpy old man
molly's in st louis hey molly how are
you
good um thank you for taking my call
sure what's up um
we
well i just feel dizzy
so we have a farm we have a rental
property and my husband has a generator
business
and our money
i feel like our money's in a good place
but
the farm operation
is a little tricky to wrap our brains
around like
how
to get it to where it's that free but
also like the motivation behind it
because
like if you
if you so we use an operating loan
while the crops are being put out and
all that
um
so it gets paid
back
and gets paid down to zero but
um if we
so if we buy if we saved it by land
you can't
deduct that uh
purchase
so you have to pay tax on anything
what's your question
if how do we get rid of our
operate i'm not really sure honestly how
do we get rid of our operating loan
uh like
what's the motive behind that when
we would have to pay so much in tax to
build up enough money to
to have the cash to do that
okay
um
you understand a tax deduction
is not a tax credit
so the operating loan does not benefit
you for taxes
except for 25 of the interest that you
pay
there's almost zero tax benefit for an
operating loan
did you know that
um
i thought our i thought what we paid on
that was part of our farm expense
no not for not not the principal not
only the interest
okay only the interest okay and so let's
put how big is the operating loan
typically
um
our limit is 225 the max we've ever done
is like 160. okay so
let's just use some crazy numbers okay
let's say you did 160 000
and it cost you
uh
eight percent of that and so it cost you
uh or ten percent of that it wouldn't be
that much what's your interest rate
four percent okay four percent all right
and so it costs you what sixteen
thousand it
costs about four thousand dollars in
interest
yeah no it costs you about
six thousand seven thousand dollars in
interest okay well the seven thousand
dollars in interest is all that's
deductible nothing else is deductible
correct okay now the seven thousand
dollar tax deduction
if you're in a 30 tax bracket
saves you two thousand one hundred
dollars in taxes
okay so you're screwing around with 160
000
for a 2 000 benefit and calling that
sophisticated that's not sophisticated
no i think the issue is more
we're not it's not really that to get
the deduction
it's like
okay so then i misspoke okay um
so if i
in order for us to build up like it's
you have to pay taxes on 160 000 worth
of income to have 160 000
yes that's how life works yeah
yeah
yeah but that's what you need to do
to get out of the operating loan
business because all you got to have is
one bad crop in your bankruptcy
hello yeah
i'm no i'm trying to just wrap my brain
around because i'm okay so here's what
you need to do here what kind of profit
do you make in a year on the farm do you
think um this last year
after we did everything we'll have like
a hundred thousand okay income and so so
let's pretend and let's say okay you
need a hundred and sixty so let's say
over four years we're going to take 40
000 a year and we're going to borrow 40
000
less each year
because the 100 000 in profit you pay
taxes on you don't have a choice
okay so after you pay taxes on your
hundred thousand dollars i want you to
put forty thousand dollars aside each
year for four years that will equal 160
000
now you are your own line of credit
because you actually have some freaking
money
and i'm curious really quick molly i'd
love dave to hear this i want to hear
this how much is the rental property
worth what do you owe on it
we don't owe anything on the rental
property what's it worth probably worth
450. what kind of profit does the
generator business make
so
real quick generally we take home five
thousand a month okay okay so
60 000 on that so you're making 160 000
a year you've got a 450 000
rental property
if i were in your shoes i'd sell the
rental property and fund my operating
line that's what i'm thinking you're 100
debt-free you're operating the business
debt free you're going to increase your
you're going to decrease your hassle
because you're dealing with a renter a
generator business and a farm
okay so you're going to decrease the
craziness where you're chasing your tail
when you started the call you talked
about how confused you were
and um and you're getting rid of the
debt which lowers the stress of the
situation and you're paying cash for
everything on the farm from this day
forward and you're paying cash for
everything in the generator business
from this day forward and you never fall
for the tax deduction myth again because
when you fall for the tax deduction myth
and you call that smart really what
you're saying out loud is i love trading
dollars for quarters
because that's what a tax deduction does
it trades a dollar for a quarter
and you don't want trade dollars for
quarters
so don't stay in debt for the tax
deduction and don't stay in debt because
you think you have to you don't have to
effectively you are borrowing against
your rental property once a year for an
operating loan
that's what the balance sheet says
it's technically not a loan on the
rental property i got that but
effectively that's what you're doing
yeah so you can clean up your whole life
pretty quickly if i were in your shoes
and i wanted to be a farmer i'd sell the
rental property
if i didn't want if i want to be a
rental landlord and not be a farmer i'd
sell a farm
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit the ramsey show dot com and
register we would love for you to come
to nashville and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host ken
coleman ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
his new book is out and on the
bookshelves and at
ramseysolutions.com flying out the door
it's called from paycheck to purpose
the clear path to doing work you love
so if you want to talk about career and
jobs this hour well mr ken coleman is
here to help
and of course i'm here to help you with
your life and your money we started
pre-sale on my first book in eight years
wow yesterday i didn't how's that feel
been a long time since you put a book
out it feels old
but um
yeah i mean basically i've been putting
your all's books out first i know so now
now you're on the cover now i have 10
ramsey personalities and putting putting
out books on 10 ramsey personalities and
supporting and pushing out those brands
and helping those has been my job for
eight or ten years and so the last book
i did was actually with rachel so she
and i did number one bestseller called
smart money smart kids
and she was of my daughter rachel cruz
is one of the ramsey personalities and
so um this one's uh not got anybody's
name on it but mine and it's all about
the people that have followed the baby
steps and have become millionaires and
it's the proof text to prove to you that
you can too
not billionaires
millionaires
have a one million dollar net worth or
greater
and then there's
that that's you would want more than
that probably that's not enough maybe i
don't know but it's a million it's
million more than most people got it
yeah you're not so if you want to be a
baby steps millionaire we can show you
how and following the baby steps gets
you there and this is a
you know truly
motivational book to show you exactly
with the math exactly with statistics
exactly what will happen with the
arithmetic if you follow this process
you will get there and it also pretty
much tears up anybody who tears
anybody's butt up who says you can't do
it and so i spent a few chapters tearing
up those butts little whack-a-mole in
there a little whack-a-mole a little
chapter little uh
solve the objection to make the sale
thing so uh people that tell you you
can't win i don't like those kind of
people so it's my job to tear their butt
up that's the thing so
um it's what we do so baby steps
millionaire is on sale now it actually
comes out january the 11th if you
pre-order it you get all kinds of
goodies including e-books and audiobooks
and 100 worth of stuff so check it all
out at ramseysolutions.com chad is in
minneapolis hey chad how are you
better than i deserve how are you
just the same sir what's up
so i've got a question um
my fiance and i have very different
views on money we're going to get
married next next summer
congratulations
yep thank you uh
grew up on a farm working saving you
know striving for a better life
one that i was destitute when i was
growing up but you know it was it was
not always the easiest thing
her mom had her
my my fiance's
grandfather passed away and her mom had
inherited millions of dollars
never had to work and ended up raising
nine kids on her own after her dad left
um and sort of abandoned the family
and then ended up using the money that
she had inherited to
manipulate the kids into doing things
into
thinking the way that she did doing
things for her
but ultimately has left sort of a bad
taste in her mouth with money
um
how do i work with her to show her that
money isn't
intrinsically evil um i am i'm the
breadwinner i i have a very good career
um you know i make about 120 she makes
38.
how do i work with her to show her that
money's not bad
how old are you guys
uh
36 and 38. okay
okay
um either one of you been married
before both of us have actually so we're
combining
i've got four boys she has two girls
okay
well let me tell you some statistical
things to think about and these are
things you can go over with her
okay
one of the things you want to do anytime
you want to enter into anything
in business we would study
if you want to enter into marketing we
would study marketing and emulate best
practices find best practices
and find where the landmines are we want
to avoid the mind land mines keep from
getting your leg blown off right
and we want to emulate people who are
winning we want to copy the things that
the people that are winning are doing
agreed
okay so here's what you guys are facing
it's not insurmountable by the way
but it is an uphill climb
you have three major strikes against
your marriage before it even starts you
don't address these
i'll give you a high probability of
failure
okay
number one
her
family upbringing was toxic
she comes from a highly dysfunctional
family
number one
hard to have relationships when you have
come from a highly dysfunctional family
unless you've dealt with it
did i did i misstate that
no okay number two you both have failed
at marriage before and if you have not
healed through those failures and
learned from those failures um you will
replicate the exact same stupid crap
again high probability of failure if you
do not deal with that that's right
number three
the number one cause of divorce in north
america today
money disagreements money fights and
money problems and you're already having
those
you have to solve all three of those
before the summer
and and to be honest with you so in both
of both of our
um both of both of us chose to leave our
marriages
due to
a lot of issues unfortunately i we we
knew each other's um
exes so we we saw it there was a lot of
people that saw it
well wonderful you still both failed at
marriage listen dude you got what i'm
trying to tell you is you guys need a
lot of one-on-one
counseling pre-marriage counseling to
deal with these three issues before you
walk down the aisle otherwise
statistically you have a very high
probability of hitting the wall yeah
don't miss this i'm not trying to say
you can't make it i'm just saying dude
there's land mines everywhere and i'm
trying to guide you through them and you
need a coach a counselor that they can
talk to the two of you that is excellent
that is world class this is not two
little puppies getting married and they
need some little pat on the hand
pre-marriage counseling you need to deal
with divorce healing you need to deal
with her toxic upbringing because her
mother's crazier than a freaking bean
man what you described to me is
dangerous stuff control and then on top
of that you're in total disagreement
have different value systems about money
and you boiled it down to she thinks
money's evil that's not the problem here
that'll be one of 14 things that come up
while y'all unpack this yeah chad i hope
you're hearing this you need to pause
this wedding date until this stuff gets
fixed we didn't say not marry her we
said pause well i don't even need to
pause it you just gotta do the work
between now and summer well i i
appreciate that dave it's very
optimistic i i think it's pause until we
get healthy and on the same page of this
and i'd say this she's gonna have to see
a desired future that you both agree on
that money helps us get there that's
eventually where you're gonna have to
get her if you can't agree about money
you're not gonna agree about life
and you guys really do have some work to
do to get ready for this marriage i
think you can do it but you're not gonna
do it if you'd ignore it
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars all thanks to
what i learned at bethel tech you could
be next get started today at
betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
have you guys heard that the real estate
market is crazy what what are you
talking about nuts
buyers out there i think they got a buy
there's a line around the block multiple
bids every stinking house listing is an
auction
i mean out of freaking control and
mortgage interest rates are
lower i don't know how they could get
any lower they're going to pay you to
take a mortgage soon i think hey don't
get me wrong a low rate's a good idea
it's not a green light to do stupid
stupid as in buying before you're debt
free or with a zero down payment or just
lining up and paying like way too much
for something because you're out of
control hey get your head out of the
craziness for a second look at you
in your situation
are you debt-free
you have a good strong down payment
saved preferably 20 that'll avoid pmi
right can you really afford home
ownership
do you really want the responsibility
you know somebody's got to cut the grass
hello if and only if your answer is a
big fat yes to all those questions then
buying a home is a really smart move for
you
and it's easy to get caught up in all
the crazinesses out there which is why
you need the facts go use our free
mortgage calculator to figure out what
you can actually afford with the
mortgage options that are out there
go to ramseysolutions.com click free
tools
to check it out
free tools to check it out
josh is with us in greenville south
carolina hey josh what's up
hello sir gentlemen thank you for your
time in advance uh my question is i
am selling my home back up in indiana
it's
set to close on the 30th and
i have not heard this question yet uh
how do i keep myself from feeling like
i've hit a jackpot and
keep myself
more along the lines of adulting i am
going to admit that i've been like
ramsay-ish along the way but i do have
plans to get my uh debt paid off
and say that's such a good question yeah
that's very good
how much is the house selling for dude
uh i
asked for 135 and i originally bought
the home nine years ago about 86 so i'm
looking at roughly 50 something
thousand dollars in your pocket and
you've never seen fifty thousand dollars
in your pocket
not in one lumps and nothing how old are
you
i am 32 okay good for you man
congratulations and that is a very
mature good solid question to answer how
do i how do i be smart wise adult with
fifty thousand dollars instead of a
child that says who i hit the lottery
well so i got a question i'm gonna add
my question on to his question
there's gotta be a psychology and you've
experienced it where there is a rapid
change in in money just period what does
it do to your head and heart
you know the only way i've been able to
work through it and i have to work
through it regularly because uh
sometimes my emotions still operate um
you know making more than one jillionth
of what i make now
uh and so i mean we spend more on copier
paper in ramsey than i used to make in a
year you know so uh it's weird it's an
emotional sure it's an emotional swing
so the way i do that is just you know
john dr john delaney says facts are our
friends yeah
and so uh what i would tell you to do
josh is just write down a lot of facts
facts are
that emotionally 50 000 feels like a lot
of money but actually the arithmetic on
it is it's not much
right you know and so like facts are i
can buy this or this or this but then
i'd have nothing facts are i i want to
do this with it so that i can turn 50
000 into 500 000 over the next 10 years
with the house buy or whatever it is
what are my facts
not my feelings feelings will lie to
your butt
yes sir and so that that's what you're
fighting against and that just means
you're just like a a real person because
we all fight against that but the
feeling is like oh man like woohoo i've
hit the lottery but then the facts are
i could fritter this away real quickly
and i really would end up with two ugly
cars and that's it you know or something
you know it would just be bad and then
you'd be mad at yourself for like a
decade for the having screwed this up
yeah and that's a fact those are facts
and you know it won't hurt to sit down
at the computer and just write some of
those things down like write yourself a
note that says you know hey let's be a
grown up here you know i i have
attendance i could be a lottery winner
and act like i'm in high school and but
adults devise a plan and follow it
children do what feels good that's what
i want to add josh while you're writing
down what dave asked you to write down i
want you to write down what your future
looks like what are you dreaming about
because dave here's what's going on
you're absolutely right
uh feelings
are always present focused
exactly
exactly plans
with future focus wisdom is an act of
the will yeah i want to think about it
distance vision is an act of the will
that's it and i think the desired future
if you plan it out and then you say
where does this new found money this 50
000. how does it plug into that and what
that does is that unplugs it from friday
night hundred percent now we got
discipline it unplugs it from a visit to
target
that's right or hey none of those things
are none of these things are wise right
because he could be tempted to buy a new
car he's got the cash but wait a second
where are you
allocate 2 000 of it to blow
to get it out of your system then it'll
go i'm going i'm going to be wise with
the other 48. i actually like that plan
because it gets the celebration factor
let's celebrate this is a nice blessing
yeah but then let's be big boys and big
girls doesn't hurt to allocate some of
it to generosity as well yeah but that
also helps but the the
the big thing is is to actually do what
you're doing with this phone call which
is be intentional and be careful and be
thoughtful because where there is no
vision the people perish dalton is with
us in carbondale illinois hey dalton
what's up
hey dave how are you better than i
deserve man what's up in your life
uh i just turned 20 and um
i'm gonna be honest all throughout high
school i kind of
was a knucklehead i mean i didn't say no
i didn't
by the way that comes with the deal
daughter
ken was a knucklehead all the way
through high school you know man i
wasn't even a knucklehead i was just an
idiot
yeah welcome to the humanities uh
yeah i um got really bad grades and all
that and
uh now i'm kind of looking more towards
the future now that life has kind of hit
me yeah i'm still left at home i've got
a paper route i make about 20 000 a year
and i'm thinking about going into the
military
so they'll pay me to go to school as
well as um
i would like to serve my country it'd be
an amazing thing and i'm thinking about
going into the police force
and it's pretty seamless to go from that
um into a city police where i'm at
um i don't actually need a college
education for it but um
if it's paid for you know i thought i
might as well take it
um but my main thing is my family isn't
quite on board with me going into the
army why just because they're
they're very very scared
um
mainly because
i'm not sure if i want to go active duty
yet or not oh they're just worried about
your safety
100 oh yeah that as well as um
i didn't tell you i am uh seventeen
thousand dollars in debt i found you
just a little too late
um i got into
a four hundred dollar car payment so
dalton before i run out of time what's
your question honey
um i was just wondering uh
what i should do as far as the military
as well as um working my way out of debt
in the meantime got it ken well i i got
to tell you i think i heard your heart
here and i think if you want to serve
our country i would not chase the
military option just as an education
fund it's not a bad move it's nothing
moral about it but i want you to decide
why do you really want to serve our
country uh and i think it's in that
answer of being a police officer you
want to protect and serve and so i say
go uh be sensitive to your parents
they're concerned about your safety but
i think you've got to do what your
heart's telling you to do and the good
news is you can pay off that car loan uh
you're 20 you didn't find dave and
ramsey solutions too late you can pay
that off in no time i mean you're making
20 from a paper route what if you went
right now in this market where people
are looking for anybody with a pulse and
they'll pay him 15 an hour minimum wage
how can you go get another job pay that
17 000 off really quickly and then step
into the military serve your country and
then find a way to step into a police
force and protect and serve your
community i think you got to do what you
want to do
heading in the right way young man
just move slowly and make sure you spend
a lot of time uh
beating up the recruiter for the best
possible deal yeah on what it is you're
signing up for and that you get into an
area of the military that's gonna serve
your long-term dreams and serve your
educational dreams make sure you get all
of that in the package
you might even have your dad or mom
involved with you in negotiating with
the recruiter
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
oh now this is fun
this is fun right here in the lobby of
ramsey solutions on the debt-free stage
our good friends
dr andrea and jim are with us all the
way from bowling green ohio i got that
right that's correct good friends of
ramsey been friends a long time and
you're here to do a debt-free scream we
are yeah
you know here's a weird fact for you
this is the second bowling green ohio
debt-free scream in a week really what
are the chances of that stinky little
town it's wonderful the lady was a big
uh the kids were at the university they
were falcons right yes yeah yeah cool
all right andrea how much debt have
y'all paid off we have paid off 158
thousand dollars
how long did this take 24 months you
rock wow and your range of income during
that time it was we started off at 130
and then we ended at 190. okay i know
the answer but the listeners don't what
do you guys do for a living i am a
clinical child psychologist and i'm a
capital project manager awesome very
cool and what kind of debt was your 158
000
well 46 000 was my student loan debt for
being going and earning a phd over 10
years of higher ed um he didn't come
into the relationship with any debt and
then the other 112 was our house
we are looking at weird people
i love it way to go you guys what's the
house worth uh 300 000 we checked zillow
just before we came up here
i like that he was ready i had an
appraised 10 minutes ago
yeah i was a project manager well done
you guys well done so a phd and a
project manager and a house worth 300
grand and you guys are how old 38 wow
36. on your way to being baby steps
millionaires if you're not already well
done you guys i'm so proud of you thank
you it's neat and i'm proud of you as
your friend too so very very well done
good stuff
all right so what inspired you 24 months
ago to get on this horse and make sure
it's done well it's a little bit broken
up so we did it in two phases so back in
december of 2013
when i earned my phd and we had that 46
000 we decided hey we're just gonna
we're not gonna pay a penny to sally may
we're just gonna get rid of it in that
six month grace period and so we just
lived off of one salary and we paid off
the 46 000 in that sixth month grace
period before we had any interest so we
got rid of that and then
we took a little bit of a break we
bought some stuff we bought some stuff
with cash with cash but you were on baby
steps four through six at that point
because you're working on your house
absolutely no other debt left but the
house at that point correct right and we
had some twins via ivf which is a pretty
penny if anyone's done ivf um it costs
quite a bit of money so we had that and
we also bought three cars in that amount
of time
with cash and not new
and then probably in december of 2019
that's kind of when we got intense about
it with paying off the house over the
course of the years we had led financial
peace university and we had walked
alongside people and one of us would say
like hey we're teaching financial peace
university we're really supposed to be
paying off the house early
and then the other one would run the
numbers and that person would be like
it's not worth it i'd be the one running
the numbers saying it's not worth it
and i would be like well maybe we should
try and he'd be like uh
no i wanna i wanna live a little bit and
i was like okay
and then we'd run some more people
through financial peace and i'd be like
we really should pay off the house and
then in december 2019 he looked at me
and he was like he ran the numbers again
and uh oh we should pay off the house oh
no there it is jim what changed uh well
when i was doing it early you know you
just buy a house you get a 15-year
mortgage how much sacrifice am i gonna
have to make to pay it off you know two
years early you know it's a ton of
sacrifice there when you're really early
to uh to pay it off that much early and
then we just after seven years or six
seven years it's like oh okay the number
i can hit is much smaller now and i can
actually felt attainable i felt
attainable yeah i could do oh in 18
months in in 12 months if we really
buckle down we can actually do this and
really having that ability to do it was
like all right let's let's get after it
and we paid it off so cool and then it
was funny because then in december of
2020 when we sat down to set up our each
of our individual goals i was like hey
for a financial goal let's pay off our
house by may 2021 and he ran the numbers
again and he's like there's no way we
can do that and i was like but let's set
it as a goal and he's like there's no
way and then
we appreciate it i love this background
we paid it in may 21st of 2021
wow wow way to go you guys how's it feel
to not have a payment in the world
absolutely wonderful yeah it's great
it's so you run the numbers on that
oh yeah give him a minute dave i i've
done the numbers of you know i also hit
zillow right before you came up with
you know how much per year all that what
are we going to have in 20 years all
that's done but
it's just the the ability to know that
you know whatever i'm whatever i have is
we own everything that we have and that
any dollar that's coming in if i'm
spending a dollar like i don't have to
worry about that right it provides us
freedoms like oh i can help someone out
you know i you know we can make
independent decisions of like oh we
don't you know our ability to make
financial decisions of just on the spot
is so much higher and being able to
feel that when someone needs something
or we want to do something it's just
it's done there's no worry about it
because we know we have the money and i
think the other thing with that is that
not only financial decisions but we can
also make career changes so after we
paid off the house in may we actually
both changed careers
in june of this year and so we both
started new jobs because we had the
financial security of we didn't have any
more debt wow good for you that's very
cool yeah because you know it's um i can
work where i want now mm-hmm
it changes everything you know i don't
have anybody breathe i don't have
anything breathing down my neck that
says i have to stay in this environment
it's really interesting the psychology
there because it gives you guys a little
bit more confidence to make the move
because it's a big deal to switch yeah
to pivot there's a whole lot of unknowns
there absolutely give you that extra
confidence it's really interesting i
gotta know all right so you're going
maybe may he's like i don't think so
maybe you just wore him down what was
the intensity i'm just curious what was
the most intense thing you guys did to
meet that stretch goal because it feels
like it was a stretch it wasn't even
really a stretch because what we did was
i had opened a private practice in 2020
2020 and we just didn't touch that money
we just kind of set it aside so then at
the end of 2020 we just took all the
money out of the private practice and
just threw it at the debt and then oh i
see so jim was spending that money and
that's why i didn't think it was
possible yeah it was in his spreadsheet
it was in the spreadsheet yeah and it's
really you know when you get that really
you took a second job really of his
second career you just put that all
towards it although it didn't feel like
that because it was where we wanted to
go career-wise anyway and just kept you
know two jobs at the the same time and
then made the transition fully for her
to private practice after we paid it off
i love it i'm so proud of you guys thank
you well done well done all right when
you're teaching financial peace
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is the key is budget
i cannot tell you the number of times
just sit down and have a budget meeting
with your spouse and sit down and run
the numbers and give every single dollar
a name
and just the
just the amount of
people realizing when they actually sit
down and do a budget and be like i
should have a thousand dollars more this
month where is it going and i'm like i
don't know you tell me you're the one
spending it and then it's just
life-changing and marriage changing it
changes your marriage when you no longer
have to fight about money yeah
very cool all right jim have you run the
numbers when you're going to be a
millionaire uh yes it's
soon if not happened so
[Laughter]
he's sly
he knows he's already there he's already
there way to go baby steps millionaires
i love it
this is why i come down here and work
still just for this there it is there it
is i'm so proud of you guys well well
done very well done excellent excellent
stuff all right who are your biggest
cheerleaders outside the two of you um
probably your parents yeah probably my
parents and you know my family's been
you know my mom got me the uh totally
money makeover when i was in college
my dad would watch you i believe fox
business on like saturday morning or
financial peace baby yeah
yeah i mean they
yeah so they just gave me that
my grandparents you know it was always
you know not having debt and just you
know being able to pay for things and
blessed me with not having any you know
debt going coming out of college um and
so that's just kind of my family's just
you know grown up in that and uh and so
they were really just just living living
how we live you know dr andrea and jim
158 000 paid off 24 months house and
everything not even 40 years old
we suspect they're baby step
millionaires i love it
making 130 190 a year count it down
let's hear a debt free scream
three two one we're debt-free
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is how it's done boys and girls
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture today psalms 86 11 teach
me your way lord that i may rely on your
faithfulness
give me an undivided heart that i may
fear your name
dr martin luther king said you don't
have to see the whole staircase just
take the first step
boy there's so much in that
so much in that just take the first step
bj's with us in baltimore hi bj welcome
to the ramsay show hi
thanks for taking my call we just love
you guys um we were doing the dave
ramsey um and we paid off all of our
debt except for our house way to go um
when we had a second mortgage so we just
have the regular mortgage now
so um the question is i have a lot of
health issues and as
i've um
i've had to go to a natural doctor
because the regular doctors weren't
working
and my husband has a year and a half
before he retires
and my aunt has offered to sell us her
trailer but we would have to relocate
and the question is
should we take early retirement
and then take the the difference
because she's practically giving it to
us
um
should we should he take early
retirement and then pick up another job
because he would need something to do
because we could actually live on his
early retirement or should he continue
working where he's at and then possibly
just rent a place and but all the
rentals are more than what are what we
would pay what do you owe on your home
we owe a
125. and what does he make
he makes uh 80.
do you not like your home
i have health issues i can't go up and
down steps
the bathroom is up on the second floor
and in the basement
so you need to sell the house for your
health reasons
yes to get you into a one-level property
we could live in the basement which has
a bathroom but it's
he really wants to live in a basement
yeah amen okay
and so your houses would sell for how
much
it would sell for uh 200 to
uh either 180 to 200 000.
and you owe 125.
yes
okay
why don't you sell it and buy a one
bedroom
or i'm sorry a one level house
around a 150.
well in this area
if you can sell yours for 200 you can
buy something for 150 that's not that
dissimilar to what you're living in
if yours sells for 200 150 175 will buy
a very nice one level on your freaking
street
okay you know this is a large house
that's got an apartment in the basement
it's all been redone okay
so sell it for 200
and buy yourself a nice
one level house for 150 to 175.
okay
so it wouldn't be a problem to have
another mortgage because he retires in a
year and a half nope because he's going
to keep working after he retires and he
makes enough to live on when he retires
i'm not moving you into a trailer
that's going down in value
there's not a good enough deal in the
world to move into a trailer
there's not a good enough video in the
world to live into a trailer that's
going down in value and this be your
signature golden years no thank you
all right so i think i think you're sick
of these stairs and you know you're just
grasping at straws trying to get out of
there but here's the principle bj that
you need to hear okay okay if you're
gonna sell a house in a market and buy a
house in the same market
you're going to sell in the like things
are crazy over there right
yeah so you're going to sell in crazy
and you're going to buy in crazy so this
is a net net it's not a net loss it's
not i sold low and bought high i sold
high and bought high
it's a net net so it doesn't prohibit
you from making the move and you you
know now if you move from a crazy low
market to a crazy high market you know
you might have an argument then but if
you moved on your same street
you you can move down in house down in
price and get into one level three
bedroom house and and the smaller than
the one you're living in and do it in
the 150 to 175 range uh if your current
home really is worth 200. now dave you
were so certain about the trailer what
if it has a redwood deck does it change
your opinion
what if it has an outdoor
above-ground pool you were still
you were so certain dave
i was like wait a second
i feel like you oversimplified that
i'm just talking about things i'm
talking about things that go down in
value that's absolutely right i couldn't
resist i'm not above any of that in
terms of being a snob that's not the
point the point is the stinking things
go down in value yeah and they're
basically a car you sleep in
alex is with us in new york city hey
alex how are you redwood you didn't see
that one coming i didn't see that okay
what's up alex
hey dudes ken how are you we're doing
great man what's up
so
i kind of have like a part i guess
student loan and retirement questions so
uh i was
as they say i was dumb and i went to out
of state school and um i let my folks
handle a lot of the
student loan stuff and borrowed more
than i needed so
um
so yeah long story short i paid off the
loans in my name to the point where my
employer will pick up
um the payments the minimum payments and
then the big one is the pan plus loans
that i'm also paying on um
uh that right now i got it down to 150
150 000. wow um
so your parents took out parent plus
loans but you've agreed morally to pay
them
yes you're not legally obligated but you
you me that's the deal between you and
your mom and dad
yes okay and your student loans are all
gone
uh all except for eight thousand but my
employer they're paying um a certain
amount per month on it what's your
degree in
accounting what do you make
right now make 80. how old are you
24. master's degree in accounting
no uh i decided to go to community
college for the 150 credits so i was
smart with that i decided not to uh
build a master's degree
you went to a community college for 150
000 in student loans debt on a parent
plus loan no
no no no no so i went to uh uh an out of
state college four-year
um
so most of
what was it 180 ended up being for the
my four years and then
i just cash flowed 2000 for community
college
because for accounting you need 30 extra
credits so i just did a community
college instead of masters
oh i see what you're doing okay yeah
he's talking about credit just talk
about getting your cpa okay
all right okay okay okay okay so you're
24 and you're making 80 grand
all right yeah well you got 150 to go
my question was like i wasn't sure like
if since it's not in my name oh yeah
it's in your name you shook your daddy's
hand
all right
yeah yeah this is your you took on this
debt you're you claimed this debt i
heard you a minute ago
yeah i don't care if the law doesn't say
you owe it but the law of the of your
household says you owed it because
you're a man and you gave your word
yes yeah so you're yeah but you're gonna
treat it like your dad because it is
your debt
the technicality of the legal
technicality don't get you out of it
you're gonna pay it anyway so you're
gonna pay it like it's your debt because
it is your debt now you took it on so
yeah 50 000 bucks a year for three years
you're done and that means you're on
beans and rice rice and beans or forty
thousand dollars a year for four years
and you're done
by the way your income is going to
increase dramatically from 80 as you
move on from 24 years old up through an
accounting degree and so all of those
increases do not go to partying or
having fun in new york they go to paying
off daddy's loan that you promised him
you would pay
yeah
did i read your mail all right
he was just running his weekend schedule
through his head right there
just canceled that vacation that
all-inclusive in jamaica that's what
just happened yellow yeah you got to
clean this mess up dude
[Laughter]
and the fast deeper you sacrifice the
faster you'll get out that's the formula
and the faster you get out the better
life you're going to have live like no
one else so later you can live and give
like no one else great job ken coleman
thanks for having me great job
james jim jim childs
that's what i like jimmy's in there
we'll be back before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the prince of
peace christ jesus hey guys this is
james senior producer for the ramsay
show did you know over 18 million people
listen to the ramsay show every week and
a lot of those people listen on one of
our 600 plus radio stations across the
country
to find a station near you head to the
ramsay show.com
[Music]
you